yeah
Mars and I have been capped human
buddies for about five years now it's
just this he's the biggest stoner cat he
just loves to sit around eat he loves
being in bags like I don't know what to
say he just loves being in bags this is
my cat rice ball he's very friendly he's
more like a dog cat he like he does not
a fit of people he doesn't scratch or
anything no he has never been outside
before but um when I moved out to LA I
did brought him with me but he never
being like actually physically on the
ground
my name is Rocco and I love cats more
than I could love anything else my first
adult job being a cat care attendant at
the SPCA and moved into cat behavior
specialist at the San Francisco SPCA
this guy is like the most special cat
I've ever met I just was realizing that
I wouldn't sell him for a million
dollars I think the benefits of walking
a cat on the leash is that they do get
that outdoor time but then there's no
chance that they're gonna get mauled or
carried away by a coyote I would say the
first piece of advice I have not all
cats are gonna take to a harness
can you stay still for a second stay
still no so right now I'm trying to put
the leash on I'm not hurting my cat I
promise I'm just kind of making him do
something that is good for him
ultimately right Scott thank you if your
cat freezes in the harness then you're
gonna have to work on its relationship
to being inside that harness before you
can take it outside so I had to call in
backup this is my roommate Abbi we are
going to attempt to put this on him yeah
the harness is on
oh my you look so cute in this she
doesn't look happy
does he look happy
as I said okay
the best advice with any type of
behavioral issue with the cat is try to
figure out how to work with them because
if it knows you want something it's not
gonna do it so if you want them to do
something then you're gonna have to
figure out how to trick them into
thinking that they want it here we go
that's chiness nope let's go this way
let's no let's go this way Mars let's go
let's go let's go treat Mars month come
on baby no we're just move on a little
Mike he's stressing me out I'm really
really stressful this is very very
stressful he's not liking this at all oh
he said he's doing better than we
thought I thought he's just gonna like
sitting one corner and doesn't move at
all he's making some kind of process
come on let's go Mars is now a wedged in
between my neighbors hedge and my front
porch we probably walked like three
steps out of apartment apartment doors
right there I just feel like maybe this
wasn't for him right you want to go back
inside
and cats we were built to serve them
that's why the ancient Egyptians
worshipped them you know what I mean
I live to serve my cat and that's honest
so if he wants to go on a walk I'm gonna
that service